why binary wouldn't it be much easier if
they just use decimal numbers yes it
would
this is a fascinating story and it's one
where what we've mentioned already when
you and I started racing around
Bletchley Park and talking about Tommy
flowers he is if you like right in the
middle of this story
why binary why not decimal it's caused
me to think about it because if you
think back to the pre electronic era
back to Victorian times think of Charles
Babbage and his famous difference
engines they're of course just like the
old-fashioned mechanical hand driven
calculators only a lot bigger so the
question was can you on a mechanical
gear wheel grind ten teeth very
accurately and equal distances apart so
you don't get slippage you don't get
nought slipping into being one yeah so
it's a mechanical challenge so ten
teeth doesn't sound like a massive feat
to deal with no it isn't but they could
do even more I wall I'm trying to say is
even earlier than that they could do
more than that there's been TV programs
on Greek Antikythera so that could
predict solar eclipses absolutely finely
machined teeth so yeah ten was pretty
straightforward for Babbage and yet he
still had complaints from his gear
cutters because the the hard scale
automation manufacture wasn't quite
there in Babbage's time and he moaned
like mad at the invoices the bills he
had to pay to his dear cutters so that
was the big problem in the mechanical
era things however did change enormous
Lee when we got not just to the
electromechanical era of relays but when
you say I'm going to be purely
electronic then back in those early days
30s 40s you were talking about
thermionic valves once again that's
vacuum tubes for those of you in North
America who haven't watched the earlier
videos what do you have to say to
yourself there well if I use those as a
logic element on and off you've got your
cathode which boils off electrons yeah
and it'll be the big voltage on it
sucking off the electrons okay
and in the middle there's a grid and by
putting what's called I think a bias
voltage on the grid if you put a heavy
negative voltage on the grid it repelled
the electrons back to the cathode plate
didn't let them through so you switched
it off so that was how it worked
yeah but you were needed heaters to boil
the electrons off the cathode heaters
power these things thousand so
power-hungry just isn't true so on the
one hand you are getting this ability to
do electronic logic elements but the
power consumption ah was a problem all
the time one reason to use binary
overwhelmingly is it's perfect for the
logic but I think the bigger question is
when you start counting things when you
start doing the arithmetic does it still
make sense to bust yourself to use
decimal because it's what we're used to
well yes and no I think is the answer to
that the good thing about using decimal
let's say that first of all is that you
need fewer digits
yeah but binary is a lot longer than
decimal obvious example of course is log
to the base 2 of 10 equals 3 point 3 2 2
and if anybody wants to produce a
t-shirt with that on I might even buy
one what it tells you is how much more
circuitry and components do you need if
you go for a binary computer than if you
go for a decimal one that is just
telling us how many more digits we know
exactly how many bits would you need to
represent 99 in binary well I know that
8 bits is 2 5 6 yes but to think this is
1 to 8 exactly so that would encompass
nighty-night right right so 99 requires
7 bits so how does that relate to this
magic 3.3 - to answer a two-digit
decimal number - if you multiply it by
three point three to two you end up with
six point six four for numberphile stuff
you round up you take the ceiling of
which is the smallest integer directly
above it you times the number of decimal
digits by 3 point 3 to 2 that gives you
a number of binary digits but if in
doubt you have to round up because you
must have a whole number of bits so
straight away you can see therefore that
the the thing that electronics engineers
loved about binary was this simpler to
build and now that is so important but
they also realized that you would need
three point three times as much
circuitry if you did binary so there was
some argument that said well even though
binary is right for the logic in a
computer
is there anything to be gained by still
sticking to decimal for the arithmetic
bit for counting numbers up not just for
doing logic operation so you could have
kind of two areas to consider one is the
actual storage of the numbers and what
is the operation of the computer right
that's right and I think the person who
really you know ones respect for him
goes up all the time Tommy flowers of
Colossus Fame was absolutely on top of
this he'd done digital logic for early
digital switching experiments in the
1930s he knew all about this done two of
his engineers who've written up in Jack
Copeland's Bok Gil Hayward and Harry
fencin said Tommy was always explaining
to us every valve you can save is that
much less power that much less heat to
worry about if we use by Quinn by what
bike why by Quinn we can save a hundred
odd valve and bike Y or bike winery base
five two things five is magic for tiny
traffic because we're coping with five
whole paper tape that's one good thing
about it the other good thing about it
is you know from the valve circuits we
design that if we're going to accounting
far in binary you only need two voltages
you can keep the miles apart that's easy
five below ground potential five above
10 volts Pam nothing is going to make
minus five look like plus five right but
the more we try to pack different levels
we have to pack in ten levels you know
what happens these voltages drift you
start getting the voltage representing a
six drifting a bit and it looks like a
certain but he said my studies show that
if we just use five voltages we can keep
them stable enough that they don't get
confused so he came up with this idea of
bike winery basically two things linked
in pairs the left-hand one did zero to
four the right-hand one also did zero to
four but knowing that it was on the
right-hand side actually represented
five to nine he said we do that chaps we
save I think it was 100 and something
valves and it's worth it because you've
got to reflect the power consumption of
Colossus was six kilowatts you didn't
want to go higher than that I mean I but
draw a comparison here to the data
center video it's funny that it's kind
of come full circle in a ways absolutely
you know sooner overcome the problems
and like Steve Furber stuff you know
with the ARM chip being low power
consumption great to do it but then
people just want more of them anyway and
you still need a data center you still
need massive backup power suppliers of
your own and you need cheap electricity
you could say that the great advantage
of that is that when you're not in a
data center the low power demands and so
on make these things possible there's no
way I want that thing replicate aimed
using thermionic valve technology not
even by Tommy flowers I do not want
third degree burns in my shirt okay
thank you very much
and much of the material I'm using here
I'll give credit where it's due
at long last this book by Jack Copeland
is really good because it's talking
about the Colossus here